welcome back everyone this is part six
in our series on contextual word
representations we're going to be
talking about practical fine tuning it's
time to get hands-on with these
parameters we've been talking about so
here's the guiding idea
your existing architecture say for the
current original system and bake off
probably can benefit from contextual
representation we've seen that in many
many contexts in nlu these days
the notebook fine tuning shows you how
to bring in transformer representations
in two ways first with simple
featurization and then with full on fine
tuning and i'm going to talk about both
of those in the screencast
the heart of this idea is that by
extending existing pi torch modules from
the course code distribution you can
very easily create customized
fine-tuning models with just a few lines
of code
and that should be really empowering in
terms of exploring lots of different
designs and seeing how best to use these
parameters for your problem i just want
to mention that really and truly uh this
is only possible because of the amazing
work that the hugging face team has done
to make these parameters accessible to
all of us
so let's start with simple futurization
and actually want to rewind to our
discussion of recurrent neural networks
and think about how we represent
examples for those models in the
standard mode we have as our examples
lists of tokens here
we convert those into lists of indices
and those indices help us look up vector
representations of those words in some
fixed embedding space and the result of
that is that each example is represented
by a list of vectors and that's
important to keep in mind we tend to
think of the model as taking as its
inputs lists of tokens and having an
embedding but from the point of view of
the model itself it really wants to
process as inputs lists of vectors and
that's the empowering idea because if we
use it in fixed embedding of course then
these two occurrences of a will be the
same vector
and these two occurrences of b across
examples will be the same vector
but the model doesn't really care that
they're the same vector we could if we
wanted to convert directly from token
sequences into lists of vectors using a
device like a vert model and that would
allow that a in the first position and a
in the third could correspond to
different vectors or b across these two
examples might correspond to different
vectors that would be the contextual
representation part of these models and
again from the point of view of the rnn
we can feed these indirectly that's
straightforward this is a complete
recipe for doing that using the sst code
and the pry torch modules from this
course code distribution so you can see
that
beyond the setup stuff which we've done
a few times the feature function is just
going to use vert functionality to look
up the examples indices and then convert
them into vector representations and
here as a summary we're going to use the
representation above the class token but
lots of things are possible at that
point
and then when we have our model wrapper
here we set up a torch rnn classifier
and they're just two things of note
first we say use embedding equals false
because we're going to feed vectors
indirectly there's no embedding involved
here and we also don't need to have a
vocabulary you could specify one but
it's not involved because fundamentally
again the model deals directly with
vectors
and then at ssd experiment you again say
vectorize equals false and that is a
complete recipe for bringing in bert
representations with the standard rnn
this isn't quite fine-tuning though so
let's think about how we might get added
benefits from actually updating those
parameters as opposed to just using them
as frozen representations inputs to
another model
what i'd encourage you to do is think
about subclassing the pi torch modules
that are included in our course code
distribution because then you will
be able to write code just that oriented
toward your model architecture and a lot
of the details of optimization and data
processing will be handled for you
this is i hope a powerful example of
that it comes from the tutorial pytorch
models notebook
it's a torch softmax classifier and the
only thing we have to do is rewrite this
build graph function to specify one
single dense layer layer we are using as
our base class the torch shell neural
classifier which handles everything else
about setting up this model and
optimizing it if we wanted to go in the
other direction and instead fit a really
deep model we could again begin from
torch shallow neural classifier and
rewrite the build graph function so that
it just has more layers essentially and
then what's happening in this init
method is we're just giving the user
access to the various hyper parameters
that they could choose to set up this
model
finally here's a more involved example
this one we start with a pi torch nn
module kind of all the way down at the
base here this is a torch linear
regression model
we set up the weight parameters here and
then we have the single forward pass
which corresponds to the structure of a
simple linear regression
now
for the actual interface we need to do a
little bit more work here so
we set up the loss so that it's
appropriate for a regression model as
opposed to the classifiers we've been
looking at up until now build graph just
uses the nn module that i showed you a
second ago we need to do a little bit of
work in build data set rewrite that so
we process linear regression data
correctly
and then we do need to rewrite the
predict and score functions to be kind
of good citizens of the code base that
allow for hyper parameter optimization
and cross validation and so forth but
that's again straightforward and
fundamentally for predict we're actually
making use of the base classes
underscore predict method for the heavy
lifting there and then score of course
is just moving us out of the mode of
evaluating classifiers and into the mode
of evaluating regression models that's
all you need to do and again
conspicuously absent from this is most
of the aspects of data processing and
all of the details of optimization the
base class torch model base here has a
very full-featured fit method that you
can use to optimize these models and do
hyper parameter exploration
and that brings us to the star of the
show which would be bert fine-tuning
with hugging face parameters here we'll
start with the pi torch nn.module
we load in a vert model module as we've
done before and make sure to set it to
train so that it can be updated
and then the new parameters here are
really just this classifier layer a
dense layer that's going to be oriented
toward the classification structure that
we want to what we want our model to
have
the forward method calls the forward
method of the burp model and you get a
bunch of representations there are a lot
of options here what i've decided to do
is just use the hugging based pooler
output which is some parameters on top
of the class token as the input to the
classifier
and when we optimize this model with
luck in a productive way not only will
these classifier parameters be updated
but also all the parameters of the spurt
model that you loaded in in train mode
the interface is a little bit involved
here so what we do is provide the user
with some flexibility about what choices
to make
build graph again just loads in the
module that i showed you just a second
ago and then build the data set is a bit
involved but what we do fundamentally is
use the burp tokenizer to batch encode
our data
and then we do a little bit of
processing on the output labels to make
sure pi torch can make sense of them
that's really it and the heart of this
is just that we're again using hugging
face functionality to represent our data
to the burp model and then this is the
really interesting part
calling the forward method and then
fitting the classifier on top is pretty
much all you need to do and of course
that opens up a world of options reps
here has lots of other things that you
could use as the input to this
classifier layer
and many of them actually might be more
productive than the simple approach that
i've taken here